there were some pretty serious feuds
between our staff in 2019 and maybe the
panel would present a couple of favorite
foods from 2019 that's always good
absolutely well you know Howard JD got
really mad at you you know 2019 has been
the year of JD's like fancy trips he's
been all over the country emergence of
JD the new JD started in early April
when he went he took his uh he went to
Cincinnati took his father and everybody
out to like the special seats at the
Reds game and then sophisticated
sophisticated religious yes mr. Windu's
leaving the house JD right and so over
the summer he started telling us about
this 10-day second honeymoon he's going
on to a year after your wedding yes so
the Napa into Yosemite Park and all over
the world so you started trying to give
him some financial advice a listener
called in the ad how not how expensive
Napa was and JD just snapped
all right that's let's revisit that JD
was inappropriate I love Courtney in New
Hampshire hi I was listening to the
whole JD talking about is honeymoon Napa
is one of the most expensive places to
go I just got back from there for six
days it was probably around five six
thousand here this lady at six thousand
dollars in between hey JD what happened
between the time like I was just talking
to you and you were normal man you just
did you get angry after I stopped you
turned into the Incredible Hulk man I'm
telling you yeah why did you see JD come
off like that
you never ever yelled at me like that
before JD no no no it's okay I kind of
like it well we found out that the wife
called him yeah give him a hard time by
the way he ended 20-19 on another fancy
trip a three-day ski vacation two days
two days no he sat in a hotel room while
his wife went skiing yeah
yeah she's skied in the morning it's
like the driver let's move on so we had
JD versus Howard
we have who's next Shirley you got I
have said well you know Robin eventually
pushes everybody's buttons around here
is that right our little problem and at
one point believe it or not 2019 Howard
she got under John Hines skin they got
it John got upset when Game of Thrones
discussion oh boy yeah if you want to
play stopping with that Game of Thrones
tell John to grow up all right John
quick rebuttal cuz I gotta get the right
you never teen ever said to someone
guess where the king is I don't want to
talk about that TV yeah there you go
that was a good fight who's next with
the fights I got one Bret was a Gary
chimed in once back in March and he had
a mouthful of food and you asked a woman
what are you eating oh boy
Jason Jason does this lean in his chair
to see back and Gary's obviously see
what's going on and that just incents
Carrie and then Jason chimed in that it
was plantain champagne
I'm sorry you're right I thought you
were a type of guy that knew when he
finished swallowing I apologize from his
reading the situation okay mr. plantains
in your office looking [ __ ] so it's a
privacy issue not a plantain issue Gary
had a bad day yeah I was the plantain 19
was a busy place to work
I guess I do owe look at Ronnie there's
a lot of Gary [ __ ] man
yeah Gary fight Harry's in the middle
everything with everybody all right we
got you next door okay
Gary got in this thing with Sal about
with this trip to a bottle rocket and
everybody's wondering why Sal was so
upset with Gary about this only bottle
rock we got here this way model rocket
was giving me [ __ ] I had a theory on why
he's always picking on me okay here we
go it's a music wine festival out of
Napa I'm one happy celebrity jealous of
[ __ ] that he doesn't get now I don't
know that's his beef sounds very jealous
in general because South thinks that
that things that I get to do he should
be doing you here shitty horse race down
to Florida was a [ __ ] shitty toaster
oven show so you feel presentation is
gonna be how when I go out public I
embarrassed the show right but he did a
movie with medicated Pete that's gonna
live forever
so who's embarrassing who you
Wow that was a good fight it's really
good
you kind of won that one a lot of Gary
fights man Gary's blood pressure yeah
let's go to Chris what do you have yes
so Ronnie had a Labor Day party oh it
was a good fun and and Ronnie has these
weird friends you know so one of the
guys at Ronnie's my rich friends don't
forget this was not a richness what are
your creepy friend no don't
new friends that he met don't come this
way it seems to me right so so one of
his friends you know a lot of people had
issues with this guy at the party brent
accused the guy of harassing Caitlin and
then the meckel's hey I know that guy
you know he was taking pictures of my
girlfriend's but all night
so Ronnie instead of getting angry at
the friend or questioning the friend
sprayed ritual at everyone in the studio
including Stephanie who was on the phone
I know from [ __ ] party that will
never happen again what did you say cuz
when you get on the air with this [ __ ]
everybody's always had such a great
[ __ ] time and now it's a whole
[ __ ] deal no no first thing I said
when I sat down I said I want to make it
clear so Stephanie did nothing through
these [ __ ] parties I tell you times I
told no [ __ ] party so why'd you do it
cuz she wanted it go to work all right
hang up the phone and go to work all the
time everybody had a great time until
they three did no no no Jason where are
you going now you're on fire thank you
this is good told you not to have the
party stuff in the cool no
for Stephanie tonight wow you were on
fire by the way let's give an update on
that fight uh-huh
we spoke to Stephanie the party's
happening again I enjoyed myself it's
happening so there all your [ __ ] the
party's having a party way to put your
foot down am i right am I wrong I have
no idea
smiling faces yes I have no clue what
you do it's a bathtub so there is gonna
be a party there might be a different
guest list though there will be
different perverts these clips are
really fantastic is there any other
fight that we need to hear about there's
one more Howard and it will probably in
my estimation I think it's the feud of
the year so Brent we talked about Brent
Swing yeah Brent's been pretty open
about it I think it's great but actor
Michael Rapaport is disgusted all right
that was a fight and he called in to
tell him how he felt where is this hate
coming you would report of something
going it's just pure jealousy it's pure
jealousy he's upset that he's a big-time
Hollywood actor because Michael married
yeah he's a big-time Hollywood actor
right but he's upset that I have a young
hot beautiful wife and that's what he's
upset about and he's upset that I'm
honest enough to get on the air and talk
about alright Michael claimed here on
Bren side is that you're just jealous
[Laughter]
you've got so many son and liver spots
on your face like how many pounds of
makeup do they have to put on to cover
that up to put you wrinkled up ginger no
I don't
wow-wow so because Rappaport's prom was
so caught up and then he almost got on
Mike and started arguing with him
smaller
of course Rappaport stuck in the 90s
right the only way he knows how to fight
is a rap battle so he wrote a song about
Brett his Espen he could suck me your
life is one big family stories are tales
your jokes are stands you couldn't get
nailed in a shower gel cuz you look like
a super Garbage Pail Kids Aspen he can
suck me yeah you [ __ ] your story's a
steamy all right
steamy is a pile of [ __ ] meanwhile bring
came back at him with an original metal
song
[Music]
what's this song is for the talk of how
his refrain in order
Mike spoke to one and that's not funny
Bain
like Ted Bundy's gear for life she
called us cop arrested his ass and put
into a
it was a pretty good song it's cool man
performative so Howard we tie it all up
with a short montage of those two
trading in tonight Bren here's your year
in 2009 ten times worse buddy you look
like Al [ __ ] the pot powder that's what
you lookin [ __ ] that's right I
came out of the swamps of Mississippi
and Florida and I got in and got my way
here you do that you were born right
beautiful